think of being in a freezer and then
somebody puts your face directly into a
big pile of wet ice cubes that's what it
feels like I'm speaking to Lisa Kelly
she's a scuba diver with National
Geographic and she leads expeditions in
Antarctica and the arctic temperatures
and Arctic waters typically range
between 25 and 35 degrees Fahrenheit
because the waters are so cold divers
have to use special gear this includes
use of a dry suit
these suits actually keep divers dry
when they're underwater I like to call
it a self-induced state of hypothermia
really because even though you're dry
you're still going to get cold and that
is such a shock on people's system
unfortunately there have been deaths due
to cardiac incident because of that
aside from the cold there are other
things that divers need to be on a
lookout for walrus and polar bears
animals like killer whales reverberate
sound we call it singing it sounds like
a gunshot underwater it can go right
through you
but Lisa Kelly says that diving in the
Antarctic and the Arctic is an
unparalleled experience and it starts on
the boat that initial feeling when you
fall back in the water it's just the
sound of you breathing through your
regulator it suddenly becomes your own
little world all of a sudden all these
amazing colors start to pop out and it
really is a whole other universe and in
Antarctica you're there in a place where
possibly nobody has ever died before
[Music]